hey guys you ever thought about using
steroids to look better with big and
ripped
muscles are you thinking about it no
don't do anything yet not before you
know exactly
what happens to your body when you use
steroids
and it is shocking let's get right to it
[Music]
i have a dream that's all i need
[Music]
now some people use steroids to gain
muscle fast
and it does really work but is it
really worth it well not when you look
at the side effects
steroids are also known as juice or
roids on the street
and its scientific name is anabolic
androgenic
steroids anabolic just basically means
muscle
building and androgenic means more male
characteristics
now you need to know that if you use
steroids it comes with a lot of
negative side effects that you don't
want let's go through the list
quickly steroids can cause severe
acne so you might struggle with pimples
and not just on your face
but on your back and shoulders as well
they can cause your liver to grow tumors
yes that means cancer and you're hard to
clog up
as well
fits of rage have you ever realized when
you look at
people who use steroids that they seem
to be very angry
a lot of time
[Music]
it makes people lose their temper and
they go into fits
of rage
now this is a sensitive one steroids
will cause your testicles
to shrink it's not a myth
it's true
[Music]
they can also make your breasts grow and
no not in a good way
building muscle but more like a woman's
and for girls they'll start growing
facial hair
almost the only good thing about
steroids is that
you will have nice muscles but
they can also shorten your lifespan
they cause hormone imbalances so even
women
can become more manly by growing more
body hair
their breast sizes decrease and also
their voice deepen
teens who use steroids might never reach
their full
adult height so that means you'll stay
shorter
than you would have been
they also cause extreme mood changes
because steroids influence the limbic
system which controls your moods
and emotions and then they cause mild
depression
irritability and later mania
delusions and rage or aggression
yes hair loss if you like your hair
don't use steroids because it will cause
greasy hair and baldness but also
for women so guys who use
steroids they just want muscles fast
and i don't want good looking quality
muscles through hard work a strict
nutritional plan
and a workout routine but is it worth
all the risks for me definitely
not not if i'm gonna put my health at
risk
just to gain more muscular big
huge muscles that's not gonna happen
and i hope you don't use it either have
patience
work hard for the body that you want
work hard to gain healthy
and quality muscles because then you
train your mind
and body at the same time now if you're
skinny and you want to bulk up but you
don't have a good diet plan and a
workout routine
and watch these videos here they'll help
you out i'll see you there
cheers guys